avec l'affrontement la nuit dernière
cette affaire prend une nouvelle ampleur
que nous révèle ses derniers
développements
j'en parle avec stéphane bertheau mail
et spécialiste en affaires policières et
terrorisme on sent le sud vertommen ont
souvent quand même cet assaut ça nous
prouve que l' enquête avance allant vers
l avance même très vite
oui elles avancent très vite c'est
souvent le cas dans ce type de dossier
parce qu'on trouve des éléments vous
savez c'est pas le genre de criminels
qui se préoccupent d'avoir un plan de
repli très élaborés d'ailleurs on l'a vu
l'un des principaux auteurs des faits a
appelé des amis à lui pour se faire
rapatrier en belgique vraisemblablement
donc on voit bien qu'on a quand même il
ya une part d'improvisation dans leur
façon de fonctionner ça a aidé les
enquêteurs et puis aussi on est dans un
réseau dont on peut parfois prendre un
bout de la pelote de laine pour le
remonter il y en a qui sont connus pour
des actes criminels donc ça fait que on
sait quels sont les liens avec d'autres
individus et on peut faire avancer
l'enquêté rapidement comme ce fut le cas
justement cet homme qu'on pensait
trouver adèle hamid à baho dans le
pensait en syrie comment ce fait-il
qu'un individu aussi dangereux un
terroriste quand même qui équipe qu'on
connaissait et puis se retrouver en
france si c'est le cas il faut le dire
clairement c'est un individu qui
représentent une cible prioritaire pour
les services de renseignement donc
évidemment ça pose la question de savoir
pourquoi il a pu non seulement circuler
sur le territoire européen
mais en plus ils auraient participé à la
préparation d'attentats avant celui ci
est il aurait pu circuler préparer ses
attentats repartir bref ça pose la
question de la collaboration d'abord
avec la belgique on sait que la belgique
est un pays qui a d'énormes problèmes
qui fait face à une situation très
difficile ce n'est la belgique c'est au
prorata l'inde est le pays le plus
important de départs vers le jihad
une faille du côté de la belgique disons
que un moment donné il va falloir
peut-être appeler les choses autrement
qu'une faille ou qu'une erreur dire
qu'on est arrivé à un tel point qu'on ne
peut plus demander aux services de
police aux services de renseignement de
fournir le travail parce qu'ils n'en
sont plus capables parce que
malheureusement on a dépassé la limite
de la machine de la mécanique judiciaire
et
là où c'est difficile probablement on
parle de cellules dormantes donc c'est
difficile de me suivre ces gens à la
demie et parce qu'on a beaucoup laissé
aller pendant des années vous savez les
organisations criminelles qui était dans
les banlieues françaises qu'on a laissé
agir d'une certaine certaine façon qu'on
avis et se développer ses réseaux liés à
la criminalité organisée qui après ont
basculé dans la radicalisation al
terrorisme ou constituer des réseaux
très bien implanté des gens qui se
connaissent qui ceux qui sont fidèles
les uns aux autres depuis très longtemps
qui remonte sur plusieurs années
plusieurs même des fois plusieurs
générations et la sarre en travail des
policiers très difficile on n'a pas eu
tous les moyens qui auraient dû avoir
pendant très longtemps et vous savez
quand on doit rattraper comme ça on très
très fort beaucoup d'années de retard eh
bien il arrive qu'on soit débordé alors
comment comme on voit que ça a des
ramifications en belgique peut-être
ailleurs en europe alors comment on fait
pour que les forces policières puisse se
coordonner maintenant qu'on a vu ce qui
s'est passé en france ça c'est le cas le
plus difficile ils doivent se coordonner
après un attentat avec une menace encore
présente et avec la pression des médias
du politique et la nécessité d'avoir un
résultat très très très rapide donc
c'est vraiment la situation la plus
difficile
il ya des réunions qui sont faites à
haut niveau et puis il ya des réunions
qui sont faites entre les corps
policiers pour essayer d'avancer sur ces
sur ces enquêtes là et ont beaucoup de
communication surtout et en france les
mesures annoncées par françois hollande
donc renforcement des forces policières
ça ça peut aider c'est quand même un
début de solution mais c'est
indispensable
on a passé les dix dernières années à
akoupé justement les effectifs dans les
corps policiers
donc là on revient en arrière on revient
en arrière sous la pression des
attentats mais c'est indispensable mais
ça n'aura pas un effet immédiat on va
pas mettre dix mille personnes du jour
au lendemain dans les corps policiers
vous savez comment c'est il faut les
recruter il faut les former il faut les
faire rentrer dans les corps en question
donc ça va se faire sur plusieurs années
sont des plans qui vont prendre très
longtemps et dans certains cas moi j'ai
vu des situations où on promettait des
renforts d'effectifs qui au bout de
trois ans n'arrivait pas parce que le
système s'épuise ou parce qu'on a changé
la vision de moins d'urgence politique
et parce qu'il ya moins d'urgence et
parce qu'il ya moins de pression donc ce
qui est annoncé aujourd'hui c'est bien
si ces mises en place mais encore
faut-il que ce soit le cas alors on
verra monsieur bertin mais merci
beaucoup merci